Herkese
merhaba
Bu benim istedim konuşmam nasıl
gideceğim Umarım güzel olur
Şöyle başlayayım ben Hem ben kalkıp
duymuşsunuzdur Slime mız var dedi Yani
tane ya hastasıyım hem de inanmamız
gerekmez muyum
yapıyorum Hep konumda
çocuklar canlının değil aynı zamanda
doldururken
bir
[Müzik]
hastalık mı bu yıllarından açıkçası şu
an yani ilk kez burada hatırlamaya
çalışalım gideceğim ben O zaman ben
çocuktum ve doktor oyunu süre
çıkarmışsınız okuyan bir sürece bakacak
olursan çocukluğunda anneni parmak
uçlarına gidiyoruz şundan oyun zamanları
var belediye orta kuvvette götürüyoruz
hele Problem nedir diye fakat promosyon
olan ortopedi hiç bir programı
olmadığını şartlarını çok güçlü olduğunu
ve baya verilebilecek söylemiş bu
şekilde söyleyince yani her için rahat
etmiş ve normal hayatımızı devam etmişiz
daha sonra abla şimdi Dünyaya Geliyor
geldik Benim fazla olduğunu bilmeden
kardeşim yani geliyor Bu çok dikkat
ettiniz bir konu Çünkü iyi çocuğun Sevda
olduğunu bile bile normal gebeliklere
çocuk yapmaya devam eden aileler var o
suyu poğaça tutun hızlı kalmak zorunda
bizi bu turumuzda üstünde aynı anda
teşhis konusu sonra çıktığında annenin
Arkadaşlarınıza kartınızı konuşamadığım
da koşarken düştü mü
derken
anlayamadığını hatırlıyorum çekmek
oynaya biliyordum sonra kardeşim derken
yürümeye başladığında biraz farklı
baktığını ve
koltuktan kalktı tutularak tatlılığı
annemler fark ediyor ve
anlamıyorum ama
zamanları hatırlıyorum hayal et
[Müzik]
Bu alacaklardır süre yani önce onu
ellerinizden Ama bu teyit etmek için
gelenek Dalı Gevrektir Amanın yapılması
gerekiyor ve bizim derdine bir arada
uzakta zamanımız olan o zaman genetik
Anladım dalı başkanı indim polislerimize
yapmış ve hatta inanmayıp
akraba evliliği değil ve bu şekilde bir
şey yok
Sonra önce üçgen yine demiş Ama ikimizin
derken ne olduğunu bir şekilde söylüyor
ve o zamanlar bizim şu an sonra
öğrendiğimiz hikayede annemle babamın da
kendi tedavisi yok
içeride önceki hakkında yürümeleri
kaybedebilirler
olacak kimsenin her şey kaybettirmez İyi
baba Üzülmeyin işte söylememiz var Ayak
baş parmağı da dedim ya iyi geçiyor mu
şeklinde Eğer açıklama yapılmış İşte bu
kadar yok ama yakında devam edilmişler
ve böyle bir olduğumuzda Bence de
nörolojik hastalıkların
zaman var mı
[Müzik]
bu
tarafa devam edecek ama hayat normal
giyeceğim bilmiyorum Annem
böyle götürüyordu onların adı sorunuydu
ilk gittiğimizde böyle orası okul
anlatımı güzel
Ablalarımız bu
şekilde ve oyunlar yapıyorduk
anlatıyorlardı ama
çok güzel o
[Müzik]
Bir
de o zaman kardeşim 2 yaşında oldu
Telefonlara kullanılmaması Çıktı işte
anneme
sağladığından buralarda duymazdan
geldiğin ve güvende yaptırmaya çalışıyor
bu şekilde davranıyorum kardeşim
anılarımız var Bana sonrasında ona Bu
bizim son zamanlarımızda Okul zamanında
ya kız arkadaşım vardı Ve benim yeri
olan bir işte oturanlar ben pasta değil
yani annemle Anladım sürekli arabalarla
bir gönderdim beraber açıkçası ve bir
parça alıyoruz
Çok güzel
anlatmışsın o
[Müzik]
bir
arkadaş olarak açık arkamızdaki mutfağa
geçip orada başlamış ama annem de gelmek
Ben bunların hepsini gerçekten sonra
öğrendim şu an hep güzel söyle o zaman
tabi ülkede ve dünyada isim yapmış evi
yiyoruz annemler Ona gittik
konuşarak geçti
ve
[Müzik]
olmayan ama ben
birazcık yanlış
bence
kalmayı herhalde ya
Ben yüzmeyi bir
sanatçı kadar borçluyuz aynı zamanda
hastane Oğuz
çok onları da kaynatıp söylemişim Sadık
iğrenç olmamış felan veremez ile
bağımsız Ben bunu çabuk kuvvetli tutmaya
çalıştık Yeni geldi işte yaptığımız daha
ya getirmiştir zengin olmasını
karıştırıp anlamı yiyelim diye Elif
arkası dönük hazır sayılır Normalde
beşte Anne ne olur başkalarına geçelim
bunda da çok kötüyüm başlamıştım ama o
[Müzik]
bu
Eğer bir zamanda olmasaydı daha Kendi
ayaklarımın üstünde fiziken hava Hatta
suyumuzu olarak duymamız içinde ve
Düşünsel olarak sırlarınız olması için
bizim ilgili eğitim almamız gerekiyor
Bunun aldılar ve
en iyi öğretmenler ve
en iyi okullarda okutmak için ellerinden
geleni yaptılar sarı en yapılardan sonra
özel okulda olmadık evlat okulunuz ilk
beş sınıfta o zamanlar Bu dört artı dört
yoktu benim alanında kardeş acıktı o Bir
dursana işte 5. sınıfa kadar sınıf
öğretmeni öğrendiğini ve çevrede en
iyisi zor bulduk durumu açıklandı Hatta
Annem hem benim hem söyleşinin
öğretmenlerini
Arkadaşım fazla olduğunda
veya kullanmak işte Hangimizde
hissettirmeden kurabiye dışını
değiştirip O
çocukların demedim Sağol canları açın
ama Ceylan'dan almıyorsun şimdi Hamza
olmak var olan hastalığı daha kötüye
gitmiş evlenmedin O yüzden
hastalıklardan bir sır bu konuda
döneminde değil ömür boyu kaçtır hiç
kimse hastalarımıza giremiyordum
sonra okula
problemleri olduğu
kardeşim Örneğin
2. 3. sınıf sayfa Ülkemize gelen
insanlarla kullanmaya başladı mı
[Müzik]
ben seni özlüyorum çok an bu şekilde
anlatmıştı Hani farklı yürümek ya da
Start kızlar yanında olmam
farklılıklar nasıl soracağınız bir şey
değil Çünkü Görmeyen bir dert gördü
topluyor herkes ne olacak diye bir şey
yok hayatta kalmak için konuşmam gerek
yok İbrahim rahatsızlığı hep ve bir
tedavi oluncaya kadar bizi mümkün
olduğunca Pastamızı düşme tutmamız
gerektiğini Açılalım yeni geldi okula
alıp tuvalet taşı atmak bir problem
olabiliyor bayağı bir unutma olabiliyor
asfalt döktüler
yaptığımızı ve
bütünlüğü arabada bekledim
diye Kışın soğukta oturdu zaten maddi ve
manevi hastalığı
daha sonra
ama geçti senle başladım ise de ilk
yıllarda verdiren yoğurt oldu çıktı
biliyordum sonra Ona gitmeye başladı
wis4 gideceğimiz için yani dereceye
gereken açıda getir gönderseniz iyi
Ortaokulda birliklerin var 7 sınıftaki
bir gün izinliyim aslında bir Barbie
hikayesi serimiz ile bunu araçtaki
kişilerde o hikaye Aslında bizim o
zamanlar kardeşim de istemiştim Bunu ben
de çok hastalığımı söylemedim ki burada
Bunu da devam Aslında bakmayın Baba
geleceğiz Ben hastalığının sonuna kadar
saklayan bir insan azalır gelince
sınıftaki Öykü yarışmasında gördüğün
geldim girdim tuttuğum ip ile ilgili bir
öykü ya bu ve
ameliyat olması gerekiyordu çok ihtiyacı
vardı Ancak numara toplanan sağ
ol Arda ve kızım hani isteyin hep ileri
işte göreyim şeklindeydi annesine hani
anne tane kusura bakma olmuyordu Ve
sonunda tane bile kutusunu açtık
gidiyoruz Çünkü vermeye başlamıştı
bunlardan geldi
markete gitti mi
bu Öyle olunca başladı bu olursun bak
sen benimle çıktığından ona bağlı bile
kutusuna Aslında diye yazmışsınız
ama
gece alayları haberin çıktı bu çıktı o
[Müzik]
o gelene kadar sonrasında hızlı ve erken
vermem yaşlardan da ben hastalığı oldu
ama
bir için hastalığı alındı ile
uğraştığını sonra tabir yayında ifade
etmiştik yapacağız hastalar için
atlamalısın Çünkü onlar çok acil
hastalığı o
ya Allah'ın bildiği için onlardan bundan
vurup da olsa çok iyi bizim içmeniz
onaylanmamış tıbbi bitkileri çalışacağım
Bizim de
oynayacağımız sağlıyordu çok yanılmışım
sizin Şubat 2019'a kadar mücadele ettik
Ve o süreçte Yok fazla kayıp olduğunu
bilenleriniz bilmesini kaybedenleri
bu oturmayıp adamlar yutkunluk
bozulanlar çok fazla olduğu Hatta benim
at eden tipi kanallarda olduğu süreçte
onu daha genç yaşta olanlar işte olumlu
yaşlarda olanlardan sonra
bu yaşta şekilde katlama alındı Ama bu
süreçte Örneğin önemli Vur baştan başa
için tehlikeli ulaştığı tüm kurumlarla
kapanmış oldu ve tüm ağrılar falan var
hareketi
davranmadığı Çünkü sen yap hastalığına
girmesi gerekiyordu sosyal devletin
görevi bunu ve bunu yapmak için bütün
ağrılar beraber hareket hepsi fos çıktı
ayrıca bizden sonra poğaça pastalarda
vardı bir oyun bir savaşlar değil bugün
tarafından tedavi işliyorlar yani şu an
herhangi ilacını almadığında Benim de
onlarca hastanın onlarda kişinin
dermanını çok fazla iyi var o da verdik
Tabii ki harman sıkıntılar var ama o
zaman bakınca sıfır dilediğin etkilerden
girmeye oldukça kırıklığı oldu açıkçası
yani bugünki ya Allah'ın tırmanış oldu
Sağlık Bakanlığı önünde bir 20 yıl kadar
buna ben tutulduğu sessiz silahı bütün
aileler oradan sizinle hiçbir şey
sormadan demir var her gün Sadece ayakta
hızlarda bu
sonunda annemin doğduğunda Sağlık
Bakanlığı 12 Kasım 2018'de sip2 verip bu
çantalar içinde başvurularda tutmaya
başlamış değerlendiriyoruz dedi
Allah'ın
yapıyoruz 2 3
[Müzik]
Bu
nasıl falan o şekilde geçmeye çalıştık
ama ama
tutamazsan artık gidip gelemeyecek siniz
böyle bir şey var ve sonrası gibi onlar
lazım Bir şubat 2019'da da
2018'de
devletten hastalığı alınması için
mücadele ettik zaten artık soruyordu
12'ye olayını tam onu iki tarafına 690
küsür sayısını arttırmanın sonrasında
artı bir artı ikram et bir artı 36/9
şekilde gittik ve bu hayet tamamını bu
hafta
hep beraber
yapıldı mı
Bu parçaların olması gerektiği bunları
mi tutmaya çalıştı olsa Biraz gecikti
pazar gerçekleşti pazarlardan farklı
olduğunu hani çok fazla bilinmeyene
geliyoruz evde ha ha
şeylere çok yanlış Kafan bir durum
sonrasında bir parçasıdır 27 Şubat
2019'da ilk dondurma aldım kardeşim de
onu 20 Mart'ta almıştı yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam Türkiye'de yaşanan ilk
yetişkin Oktay'ın 18 yaşıyor su21 buçuk
yaşında tedaviye başladım Sadece size 16
yaşında başlamıştı bu adam
durduk bazı giysileri de geri tamamlarım
başladı kardeşim sonu dokunmadan size
işte ah ah
[Müzik]
O da
Nikon oldum ya hemen tanıtmaya daha
eğlenmeye başladım ve onun aç Oh aydır
şu an bugün muhtemelen ne olacaktım
isterken
Allah için beni aklından şu an kendi hep
ben yapmak istiyorum yani daha bir
bırakmış değil o zaman net ekleyerek
oturuyorum bacaklarımız gereken yani Dur
masası dolması soğan da bu şekilde de
oturmayacaksın çok büyük ihtimal de
tabii ki normal Temelli oturdum
sağlığında ama böyle olacaksın
dediğim gibi
sorunlardan biri bu buraya gelmekle
biraz
daha da
bu oyunda Teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Ama
dediğim gibi
programı Programı
[Müzik]
olarak Elimden geleni yapmaya
çalışacağım
yapacağım Çünkü o
[Alkış]